anti-government protests in Hong Kong
are showing no sign of letting up tens
of thousands of people took to the
streets on Sunday for a seventh weekend
in a row the rallies were initially
sparked by a controversial extradition
bill though the bill has now been
suspended the protesters are worried
about an erosion of freedoms under
Chinese rule and say they want free
elections
our correspondent Phoebe Kong is
monitoring the situation and she joins
us now from Hong Kong for more so Phoebe
the 7th weekend of protests in Hong Kong
but it seems that this time police are
not taking any chances of we're hearing
about additional security measures what
more can you tell us
the atmosphere of today is absolutely
very tense in over the protest area
right now what I am here we can see the
team the rally is like passing through
like at my back and they're going to the
government headquarter right now and a
police have deployed I hundreds if not
thousands of police officers around Hong
Kong Island to prevent any like violence
clashes that happening possibly into
later on today and yesterday we know
that the police they have arrested
several people all of that they are
suspected of producing some kind of like
bombs and they are like having some
highly explosive materials in a factory
so this is also like one of the reasons
why the police say they are very
cautious about like what's going on
today and now studied at the government
and also some of the protesters they are
worried about like things will go out of
control like after the rally the
peaceful rally today well it's safe to
say that China is monitoring what's
happening in Hong Kong very closely it's
called the protests it's blaming the
protests on extremists external forces
but how much longer do you think Beijing
is going to tolerate this challenge to
its authority over Hong Kong
yeah you're right this is definitely one
of the biggest and largest movements
since Hong Kong was handed back to
Chinese food in 1997 in 20 years ago and
there are some rumors recently in recent
weeks that saying that China Chinese
government they might have a chance to
deploy the the Chinese army - like - in
Hong Kong to control the situation if
the situation's really like go out of
control and things turn really valancy
but this is a very sensitive move if the
Chinese government really decided to use
the army to control the situation and
this would further like harmed Hong
Kong's reputation and economy and this
is not something like really easy to do
that because firstly Hong Kong
governments have to declare a state of
emergency before the Chinese government
they deploy the army to control the
situation so in the short term this
might not happen but in terms of like
politics and politically it is expected
that the Chinese government they will
tighten the grip over Hong Kong further
because obviously the husband government
and the top leader caralyn they lost all
the trust and and the integrity so it is
very likely that for the government the
Chinese government to further the grip
over Hong Kong all right Phoebe Kong we
have to leave it there thank you so very
much for your reporting